if we manage to figure out how to drive
life's evolution
um in in it can if it can evolve uh a
sophisticated sort of informatic
um processing system like this you may
ask yourself what might chemical systems
be capable of independently doing under
different circumstances
yeah so like locally they're intelligent
locally they don't need the rest of the
shebang like they don't need the big
they need so that that's that's a great
segue into what makes this biological
right the the hearts of the cellular
activities are translation you kill
translation you kill the cell yes you
not only the translation itself you kill
the component that initiates that you
kill the cell you kill you remove the
component that elongates it you kill the
cell so there are many different ways to
disrupt this Machinery they all depart
all the parts are important now it it
can vary across different organisms we
see variation between bacteria versus
eukaryotes versus archaea right so it is
not the same same exact steps but it can
get more crowded as we get closer to
eukaryotes for instance but you are
still Computing about
um 20 amino acids per second right this
is this is what you're generating every
second the single Machinery is doing 20
a second 20s 21 for bacteria I believe
eight four eukaryotes or nine 21 a
second I mean that's super inefficient
or super efficient depending on how you
think about it
I think it's great I mean I can yeah but
it's way slower than a computer
could generate a sort of simulation I I
think if you can show me a computer that
does this we are down here well this is
the big this includes the five things
not just but I could show you a computer
that's doing the informatic right like
yes you can show me that but you cannot
show me the one that has all for now for
now I will ask you about probably what
uh Alpha fold right uh I think the more
we learn about and this is why early
life and origin is also very fascinating
and applicable to many different
disciplines there's no way you see this
the way we just described it unless you
think about early life and early
geochemistry and uh earliest emergent
systems but going going back to
the biological components
all of these attributes that we think
about life or that we associate with
Biology stems from translation and as
well as metabolism but
I see metabolism as a way to keep
translation going and translation keeps
metabolism going but transition is
arguably a bit more sophisticated
process for the reasons that I just
described so metabolism is a source of
energy for this translation process it's
so it's a it's a way to process
materials and it is inherently Dynamic
and it is flexible but it is not focused
on rapid reputation as translation does
so that's the main difference
translation is the kind of in a way just
it repeats right so you have the
metabolism that can synthesize materials
it creates or benefits from available
energy and again it's a dynamic system
and then you have computation that it
that is inherently repetitive right
needs to carry out repetitive processes
uh it and it does the tasks and it's it
implements an algorithm but it is not
Dynamic so you see both of those
attributes in Translation combined it is
repetitive and it is dynamic and it also
processes this information so they are
fundamentally different I don't know if
you can get
um the life if you don't find a way to
process the information around you
in a repetitive Dynamic way yeah and
somehow that that's what uh got
um selected maybe not selected I don't
know if it was
um accidental but that that's what it
seems to be conserved for four billion
years that that's what life established
what's the connection between
translation and the self-replication
which seems to be a another weird thing
that life just started doing wanting to
just replicate it I think when we truly
understand the answer to that question
we may have just made ourselves live
right we I don't think we know quite how
translation Machinery as a whole fits
into equation because so we try to
understand
um ribosomes RNA how the linear
information is processed
um
or the genetic code wise this codons not
others why 20 not more not less and we
are sort of moving towards transition
that's that's what we're working on
anyway uh to finally look at the
patterns in which this system operates
itself and if you understand that you're
really unlocking a very emergent
Behavior
uh one of the things you didn't mention
is physical is there something to
mentioned about that component that's
interesting there's actually a paper uh
published in 2013 I want to say the
first author zirnoff so they uh surveyed
a computational
um engineered systems level computation
energy consumption
okay and they try to understand whether
the universe is using its own or life is
using its full capacity of energy
consumption and whether
um if different planets in the universe
had life would the capacity would
increase or decrease it does life
operate at its energy maximum
and uh and they think that it does that
it actually operates at an efficiency
that is far more above and beyond a
computational system how's that possible
to determine at all that you tell me
that's why I dropped the citation I I
found the citation it's quite an
interesting paper it's a bit you know
it's a um
it's a obviously you can only calculate
and infer these things but that's a good
question to ask is the life that we see
here on Earth and life elsewhere in the
universe is it using the energy most
efficiently yeah yeah it seems to be
very efficient and again if we compare
to computers it seems to be incredibly
efficient at using it I think they look
at the like the theoretical Optimum for
electronic devices and then try to
understand where life falls on on this
and life is certainly more efficient and
that's ultimately the physical side how
well are you using for this entire
mechanism the energy available to to you
and so given given all the resilience to
errors and all that kind of stuff it
seems that it's close to its maximum yep
and this this paper aside it does seem
that life obviously that's the
constraint we have on earth right is the
amount of energy
yeah so that's one way to Define life
well
the input is energy and the output is
what I don't know
self-replicating
wait how okay let's go there how do you
how do you personally Define life do you
have a do you have a favorite definition
that you try to sneak up on
um
is it possible I Define life
on Earth I don't know it depends on what
you are defining it for if you're
defining it for finding different life
forms then it probably needs to have
some quantification in it so that you
can
um
use it in in whatever the mission that
you're operating to me like it's not
binary it's uh this is like a seven out
of ten
I don't know I I don't I don't think
that defining is that essential I think
it's a good exercise but I'm not sure if
the if we need to agree
um a universally defined way of
understanding life uh because the
definition itself seems to be ever
evolving anyway right we have the NASA's
definition it's it says
it has its uh minuses and pluses but it
seems to be doing its job well what what
are the different if there is a line and
it's impossible or unproductive to
Define that line nevertheless we know it
when we see it
is one definition that the Supreme Court
likes
and that's a
kind of an important thing to um
to think about when we look about when
we look at life and other planets
so how do we try to identify if a thing
is living when we go to Mars when we go
to uh the different moons in our solar
system we would go outside our solar
system to look for Life yeah on other
planets it's unlikely to be a sort of a
Smoking Gun event right it's not going
to be hey I found this you don't think
so I don't think so unless you find an
elephant on some exoplanet then I can
say yeah that's there's life here no but
is there a dynamic nature to the thing
like uh it moves
it has a membrane that looks like
there's stuff inside it doesn't need to
move right I mean like look at plants I
mean they they grow but there are plants
that or can be also pretty dormant and
arguably they are the most they do
everything that is one of my
favorite professors once said that the
plant does everything that the giraffe
does without moving so the movement is
not a Zen statement necessarily but at a
certain time scale the the plant does
move it just moves slower yes it moves
pretty I would I would say that and it's
hard to quantify this or even measure it
but it is a
um life is definitely the chemistry
finding Solutions right so it is
chemistry exploring itself
and and maintaining this exploration for
billions of years so okay so planet
is a bunch of chemistry
and then you run it and say all right
figure out what uh what cool stuff you
can come up with that's essentially what
life is given a chemistry what is the
cool stuff I can come up with if that
that embarks upon are maintained in a
form of memory
right so it's this you you don't just
need to have the
uh explore exploring chemical space but
you need to also maintain a memory of
some of those solutions for over long
periods of time so that's the memory
component
makes it more living to me because
chemistry can always sample right so
chemistry is chemistry but are you just
constantly sampling or are you building
on your former Solutions and then
maintaining a memory of those Solutions
over billions of years or at least
that's what happened here chemistry
can't build life if it's always living
in the moment the physicists would be
very upset with you okay
so memory could be
fundamental I mean life is not just like
I mean life is obviously chemistry and
physics uh leading to biology so this is
not a disciplinary
problem of one discipline trying playing
other discipline it's that but what what
you need to have is definitely a big
chemistry is everywhere right I
tend to think you can be a chemist you
can study chemistry you can study
Physics you can study geology anywhere
in the universe but this is the only
place you can study biology this is the
only place to be a biologist that's it
yeah so so definitely something very
fundamental happened here and you cannot
take biology out of the equation if you
want to understand how that vast
chemistry space how that General
sequence space got narrowed down to what
was what is available or what is used by
life you need to understand the rules of
selection and that's when Evolution and
biology comes into so the rules of
natural selection operate to you on the
level of biology
rules I don't know if there are any
rules like that would be fascinating to
find in terms of the biology's rules
that's a very interesting and
um it's a very fascinating area of study
now and probably we will hear more about
that decades to come but if you want to
go from the the broad to specific you
need to understand the rules of
selection and that is going to come from
understanding biology yes